I am God Gingka dendron and I'm the
asia-pacific CTO for cloud platform and
I'd like to give you an understanding of
IBM virtual private cloud or V PC at a
very high level it is a mechanism to
logically isolate cloud resources by
defining Network segments and routing
rules some of the key benefits of this
virtual private cloud is speed to deploy
network segments and rules quickly
reducing costs without the need for
physical network devices and the agility
to modify network rules as needed so
let's briefly discuss the key concepts
behind IBM V PC it's within a V PC where
we're going to create and design our
network and workload architecture the
first concept we need to be aware of is
the notion of a region a region can be
thought of as a separate geographic area
within a region we can deploy a V PC a V
PC can encapsulate zones which can be
thought of as an isolated infrastructure
location if we wanted to deploy service
for high availability we would do so by
deploying them across multiple zones
within a region within each zone we can
define subnets which logically divides
IP networks by doing so we can place
different compute resources depending on
the routing rules for that subnet and
govern traffic to those resources
considering a three-tier architecture
consisting of a web server app server
and database server we're going to do is
design our network segments according to
those tiers first we have to pick an IP
address range and define it using Saida
block notation we'll assign for zone 1
the 10.10 da-da-da-da-dah 16 IP address
range so basically we'll need to define
subnets within this IP address range for
our web tier let's define 10.10 10.0 -
24 as our IP address range this
basically means we can assign 256 IP
addresses however you have to take into
consideration reserved IP addresses used
by IBM with inside a block range which
leaves us with 251 addresses that can be
used for hosts within this subnet we can
adjust the number of hosts by altering
the netmask value next we can create our
application tier and database tiers with
IP address range 10 10 20 0 - 24 and
10.10 - 24 respectively to restrict
access to the subnets and to the
specific compute resources within each
subnet we can define security group and
access control lists ACLs restrict
inbound and outbound traffic to a subnet
while security groups act like a virtual
firewall and controls traffic to your
virtual servers in our example we can
define a security group for servers in
our web tier that can accept traffic
inbound from port 80 and all outbound
traffic we can define similar security
groups for our app tier and database
tiers for added security we could also
provide ACLs that allow for deny traffic
inbound and outbound so to design an H a
architecture to ensure that in the event
of a resource failure in a particular
zone you can failover to resources in
another zone we can basically replicate
the resource deployment in zone 2 in our
example we will replicate the web app
and database tiers in zone 2 using three
additional subnets the dot 30-20 4.40
dot 50 - 24 respectively we can then
extend out the security groups and apply
the same ACLs and attach this to the
newly created subnets so we have similar
firewall and accessed rules defined in
zone 2 to support user traffic and scale
our environment appropriately you can
attach a public load balancer that will
test back in connectivity to the web
tier servers and we can apply load
balancing rules such as round-robin to
route traffic between each server based
on inbound requests for restricted
subnets we can also attach a private
load balancer with similar load
balancing rules without public facing
accessibility in our example we have a
public load
attached to a web tier and a private
load balancer situated between the web
and application tiers and finally we
have traffic from the application tier
connected to a provisioned database
instance called DB one we can set up
replication policies in DB 1 2 DB 2 and
failover using clustering capabilities
but we have simplified this in the
diagram so this is VP C in a nutshell
for more information follow IBM cloud
[Music]